data from the office for national
statistics shows another big rise in
covid cases more than four and a quarter
million people in the uk had the disease
in the week to last saturday up a
million in just seven days look at a
chart and you can see how the infections
have surged since the second half of
february driven by the more infectious
ba2 subvariant of omicron and the
lifting of all restrictions and now
close to the record peak for the
pandemic in january the highest rates
are in young children more than eight
percent had coveted but there will be
more concern that five percent of people
over 70 had the virus and they're of
course much more likely to become
seriously ill so are they well data from
the uk health security agency shows
hospital admissions and people over the
age of 75 are now higher than they were
at the peak of the omicron wave at the
start of the year the hospitalization
rate for every 100 000 people over 85
was 178 last week compared to 158 in
january and in people between 75 and 84
it was 74 last week compared to 70 in
the january peak now that looks alarming
but the health secretary has said 60
percent of people testing positive in
hospital are being admitted to treat
other conditions not covered
for now the vaccine appears to be
holding up reasonably well but it's
beginning to wane as shown by other data
from the health security agency
it looked at people with respiratory
disease needing oxygen ventilation or
critical care now immediately after the
booster the jab was 95 effective at
preventing such serious disease but 15
weeks after the booster that had dropped
to 87
it's a relatively small drop but if lots
of older people are being infected it
could add up to lots more hospital
admissions
and that's why everyone over 75 is now
being urged to book a spring booster to
top up their immunity